Hi, are you in there?
If you are, can this happen another day?
So you're getting rid of your old stuff?
I got fired from my job and my wife left me.
If I'm honest, I saw this coming a mile away.
Thanks for warning me.
We've gotten some complaints about someone living on their lawn.
This is my corner, I'm not leaving my stuff.
The City of Arcadia allows a property owner to hold a yard sale for no more than five consecutive days.
This buys you three days.
I was thinking, you might wanna come work for me?
Stay here, you sell a couple of things.
What are you offering?
I'll give you bathroom and cigarette breaks as required by state law.
I don't smoke.
Good. Great.
You know, you can't live like this.
Why not?
It's not normal.
How much for this?
You wanna buy that? 50 cents?
I'll give you 25 cents.
Yeah, I just can't do that.
Once you get rid of all that stuff, you're gonna feel great!
Just wanted you to know, I'm selling it, all my stuff...
...and it feels pretty good.
You have a good heart Nicholas, that doesn't change.
How much have you had to drink?
In my opinion, not enough.
You're gonna have to come with me.
I wanna learn to play baseball.
Why don't you wanna play soccer?
Black people don't play soccer.
Whole continents of black people play soccer.